j'ai choisi de parler à visage découvert
et parce que j'ai envie de sortir de la
route et j'ai envie de dire aux femmes
qui ont vécu ça que il faut pas il faut
pas avoir honte de ce qu'on a vécu et
moi je n'ai plus honte de répondre de
mon histoire
évidemment ça ne s'est pas fait tout
seul j'ai donc j'ai donc écrit ce livre
et c'est à cause de ce livre que ce soir
je peux être là et que je peux parler
tranquillement mon histoire je crois que
sans fin sans l'écriture
jamais j'aurais pu faire ça mais j'ai
dit tout ce que j'avais vécu senti
pendant trente ans après le viol dans ce
livre là et maintenant j'ai trouvé une
sorte de paix je suis je peux vous en
parler ce soir vous avez entendu ce qu'a
dit à ce qu'a dit madame y
olemps s est passé avec son frère on
l'accusé d'être consentante etc vous ça
s'est passé avec votre père vous avez à
peu près le même âge 14 ans 15 ans etc
mais
vous m'avez dit j'ai l'impression de
rêver parce que ça n'était jamais arrivé
je suis plus soutenu de rien le
lendemain mais ça s'est passé une nuit
est bon la nuit c'est terrible parce que
on la nuit il ya aussi les rêves et les
cauchemars et c est bon après le
lendemain quand je me suis réveillé je
je j'avais un trou noir dans la tête
un blanc dans ma tête je ne savais plus
ce qui s'était passé j'étais
horriblement angoissé mais je savais
seulement que j'avais le souvenir de mon
père sur moi et c'est tout mais tout ce
qui s'était passé j'en n'avais aucun
souvenir et j'ai mis trente ans à
retrouver la mémoire de cette nuit là
d'ailleurs j'ai demandé à mon père de
m'aider il ya six ans j'ai écrit une
lettre à mes parents pour dire que je ne
pouvais pas aller les voir parce que
chaque fois que j allais j'étais malade
et je n'en pouvais plus de cette espèce
d'hypocrisie de jouer à la petite fille
gentil qui fait comme si rien ne s'était
passé et j'ai donc demandé à mon père de
me dire ce qu'il avait fait il m'a
répondu et bon ça a été très dur pour
moi parce que finalement jusqu'à la
langue pendue par écrit oui jusqu'à la
lettre de mon père je me défendrai
toujours en me disant que c'était
peut-être pas vrai enfin il y avait
toujours cette espèce d'espoir que
c'était pas vrai et si vous voulez on
n'a qu'une envie c'est d'avoir rêvé
effectivement et on se défend comme ça
mais pourquoi pourquoi de ces la même
question qu'on peut se poser à propos de
toutes les victimes pourquoi est ce que
vous n'avez rien dit par exemple à votre
mère d'abord ce que j'avais vécu ça
n'avait aucun sens pour moi
si vous voulez ça n'a aucun sens si
votre père devient votre amant une nuit
pour devenir votre père le lendemain
matin sans qu'un seul mot soit prononcée
comme si c'était la chose la plus
naturelle du monde alors tout bascule
enfin tout ce que vous avez vécu le sens
des mots plus rien n'a de sens et on
enfin on ne peut pas penser à ça c'est
comme la bim
si vous essayez d'y penser tout explose
dans votre tête c'est pas pensable donc
qu'il voulait ce qui est terrible après
c'est que j'ai cru que j'étais enceinte
d'un monstre est la seule issue que j'ai
trouvée parce qu'évidemment je ne
pouvais pas dire ça à ma mère parce
qu'elle est la honte qui avait
l'impression que j'allais tout détruire
que donc j'étais la plus grande des
pécheresses du monde en fait ces choses
là et donc je n'ai rien dit j'ai
simplement cesser de manger et j'ai fait
une anorexie mentale de neuf mois et ma
mère me supplier il me disait pourquoi
pourquoi tu manges pas et je ne pouvais
pas lui répondre
j'avais l'impression que ce qui m'est
mots si ces mots la sorte et j'allais
tout détruire et jallet la tuer mais
vous saviez confusément on parlait tout
à l'heure de cela ensemble
vous saviez confusément que c'était pas
bien fort bien sûr mais je ne savais pas
trop je ne savais pas du tout comment on
faisait les bébés etc
j'étais en pension chez les soeurs et
j'étais dans un milieu très catholiques
eux ou la sexualité était absolument
interdite et on n'en parlait jamais il y
avait aucun mot pour dire ça donc mais
seulement j'avais bien conscience qu'il
s'était passé quelque chose qui ne
devait pas se passer c'est tout et vous
avez pardonnez-moi mais laisser faire
oui alors pendant des années je me suis
torturé en sentant que j'étais là
coupable que c'était ma faute que
j'aurais dû fuir que pourquoi je
pourquoi j'avais pas crié pourquoi à
vendre ces choses là et j'ai lu pas mal
de témoignages de femmes qui racontent
tout la même chose si vous voulez on a
tout les mêmes mots pour te dire la
scène
on utilise toutes les mots pétrifié
hypnotisé je ne pouvais pas bouger mes
larmes sortait mais je ne pouvais rien
dire
c'est ça qui est absolument terrible
c'est que c'est une situation tellement
inimaginable qu'on est complètement
pétrifiée
[Musique]